(narrator)
Holding her own head aloft,
blood streaming into her mouth
and those of her
female followers,
feet planted on a
copulating couple,
Chinnamasta is an
audacious incarnation
of divine feminine energy.
A Buddhist and Hindu
tantric goddess,
her name translates
from Sanskrit to
"She who is decapitated."
But while chopping
off your own head
seems like a pretty
decisive move,
Chinnamasta is, in fact, a
goddess of contradictions.
One who balances a fine line
between giving and receiving,
self-preservation and sacrifice,
reproduction and death.
[light eerie music]
As a tantric goddess,
Chinnamasta rears
her distinctive head
across a range of
cultures and scriptures.
Tantra, an intricate system
of beliefs and practices
that originated in India
in the middle of
the first millennium
is practiced by both
Hindus and Buddhists.
Tantric rituals include the
use of mantras, meditation,
coded language, and
deliberative gestures.
They are intended to
channel enlightenment
through the physical body.
The Hindu tantric
tradition celebrates
the divine mother Devi or
Shakti, as a supreme deity
who comes in many
different manifestations,
from the demon-slayer Durga
to the golden Kamala,
Granter of Peace.
The Dasa Mahavidyas,
or Great Wisdoms,
are 10 interrelated
forms of Shakti
whose purpose is to
extend human awareness
beyond regular
levels of perception,
guiding their worshipers
towards fundamental truths.
Chinnamasta is the sixth
of these wisdom deities,
a fearsome figure
who can transcend
the limits of the mind.
There are numerous origin
stories for Chinnamasta,
but many involve a
combination of sex, hunger,
and radical sacrifice.
In the Prana Toshini Tantra,
a collection of
Hindu tantric texts,
the gentle incarnation
of Shakti, Parvati,
was bathing outside
with two attendants.
Without warning, she became so
aroused that she turned black
and yet her two
hungry attendants
wouldn't stop
pestering her for food.
They were so unrelenting
that Parvati performed
a scandalous act.
She sliced her head off with
her razor sharp fingernails,
assuming the form
of Chinnamasta,
the decapitated goddess.
Blood gushed from her neck
and poured into the
mouths of her attendants,
her severed head
catching the blood
in her still living mouth.
In another story from this
collection, Parvati and Shiva
were having an intimate moment,
but no sooner had
their passions abated,
then here come those
two attendants again,
begging for food.
Once again, Parvati severed
her head to nourish them
and take the form
of Chinnamasta.
In these versions of the story
hunger and sexual
desire are intertwined.
Both appear
to sap human energy,
but Chinnamasta
transforms these cravings
into the source of power.
Buddhist tantric texts
named the decapitated
goddess as Chinnamunda,
and there are subtle
differences between the two.
But scholars generally
agree that Chinnamasta
and Chinnamunda are
the same goddess,
ones also known by 1,000 plus
names in tantric scripture.
In Buddhist Tantrism,
Chinnamunda is a form
of the Supreme
goddess, Vajrayogini,
a goddess who embodies
passion and love without ego.
Buddhist texts do not explain
the origin of Chinnamunda,
but there are several
manifestations of the goddess
who slice off their heads,
including two sisters
and a princess
who can decapitate
themselves at will
to prove their divinity
to those who doubt them.
As Chinnamunda, Vajrayogini
displays her supreme
yogic ability and her
unattachment to ego.
Whatever name she is going by,
it's important to note that
the decapitated goddess
is always able to place her
head back on her body at will,
indicating her defiance of
death and powers of renewal.
Across all texts, the
goddess is depicted
with red or orange skin,
naked, save for her jewels,
a garland of skulls and a
snake coiled around her waist.
The skulls stand for
her ability to transcend
the passage of time
and the fear of death.
While the snake, as a
symbol of immortality,
cements her everlasting life.
Her lavish jewelry is
also rich with symbolism,
with her five mudras or
ornaments symbolizing
the five virtues of
giving, morality, patience,
perseverance, and meditation.
Chinnamasta's body itself
stands for a sixth virtue,
Prajna or insight.
Her third eye reinforces
her possession
of a deeper form of knowledge,
as well as her balanced
perspective on past,
present, and future.
It's rare for Chinnamasta to
look directly at her devotees,
rather by looking unflinchingly
back at her severed body,
she directs her followers
to scrutinize themselves.
It would take a lot more
than a bit of introspection
to make Chinnamasta flinch;
as suggested by her wielding
of a bloody sacrificial knife
and her warrior stance.
With one foot advancing
in front of the other,
she stands poised to
defend her followers
and to destroy the
forces of ignorance.
Chinnamasta certainly
cuts a shocking figure,
but while blood is more
commonly associated
with the demonic,
in this case it also
functions as a vital
and life-giving substance.
By spilling her own blood and
feeding it to her followers,
Chinnamasta actively
converts bloodshed,
usually a symbol of draining
life, into a life force.
But the question remains,
who benefits from
this life force?
Is Chinnamasta's self-beheading
an act of castration
that dilutes her powers?
By decapitating herself,
does she not make the
ultimate sacrifice
for her materially and
spiritually hungry attendants?
Decapitation is a common
trope in Indian mythology,
which is typically
inflicted as a punishment
or an act of self-annihilation.
On the surface, a beheading
seems like a pretty fast way
to lose your agency.
But if we look a
little more closely,
characters who meet this
fate are often transformed
into something greater
than themselves.
While losing your head
is undoubtedly
a violent occurrence,
it can also be about
severing the ego
and transcending
earthly circumstances
for the sake of enlightenment.
Similarly, Chinnamasta
appears to give herself up
to the needs of her attendants,
who pester her mercilessly for
food, even when she's busy.
In some texts, their
incessant demands cause her
to turn her attention
away from her own arousal
and satisfaction, and
to redirect her energy
towards fulfilling their needs.
If we understand
giving and receiving
as fundamentally
opposed acts, then sure,
maybe it's giving up a
lot to chop off your head
and let your blood flow freely
just to please your friends,
but Chinnamasta is also gaining
something in the process.
By cutting off her head,
she liberates herself
from the perils of the mind,
like egotism, self-delusion
and toxic thought cycles.
This allows her to become
more present and powerful
in her body, which in
tantric teachings is seen
as the most important instrument
of spiritual enlightenment.
In this framing, nourishment,
sexual fulfillment,
and spiritual enlightenment
are not entities to be found
outside of one's self.
Instead, Chinnamasta summons
the power to satiate herself.
Thus we can view
her shocking act
as one of self-preservation,
not sacrifice.
At the same time,
this does not mean
that this is a selfish
spiritual quest.
Again, she's a goddess
who encourages us
to think beyond all
binaries, so buckle up.
Although Chinnamasta has
transcended all limitations,
her spiritual perfection
comes from her freedom
to help and nourish those who
are still on their journeys.
Although her attendants
have their heads intact,
signaling their
relative inferiority,
the goddess's lack of ego
gives her the capacity
to aid all other beings.
As she merges the role
of giver and receiver,
sacrificer and sacrificee,
subject and object,
she shatters the illusion
of duality itself
and reveals the interconnection
of all living things.
For this goddess,
even death and life
are not really separate.
As the iconography of
her active fertile body
overlaid with deathly and
violent imagery suggests,
Chinnamasta experiences
both at once,
and therefore outstrips
earthly limitations.
Chinnamasta's highly
paradoxical position
is associated with both
destruction and reproduction.
In Buddhist tantric depictions,
she's usually planted on Kali,
a personification
of time and death,
indicating the
goddess's capacity
to vanquish these forces.
In Hindu tantric depictions,
she has shown standing
upon Kama and Rati,
the gods of love and desire,
but is she trampling the famous
couple or protecting them?
In some cases, her position
above the couple may represent
her epic self-control;
just another way in which
Chinnamasta masters herself.
It could also
indicate her mastery
of the cycle of life itself.
With her ability to
perpetually obliterate
and re-enliven herself,
Chinnamasta becomes a powerful
symbol of reproduction
to rival the entwined couple.
Another reading might
focus on the imagery
of the lotus flower
and inverted triangle
that often appear
in these depictions.
These signs associate
Chinnamasta with fertility,
abundant sexual energy,
and the divine feminine.
While the rest of the picture
keeps her bodily autonomy
at the forefront.
Chinnamasta's Yantra
or geometric diagram
that acknowledges
her presence
and guides
meditation on the goddess,
also conjures the
divine feminine
with its womb-like imagery.
After drawing the symbol,
tantric scripture instructs
worshipers to offer
flowers, food, ornaments,
and more to the goddess.
They also recite
suitable mantras
while meditating and
performing specific gestures.
While these rituals and
their meanings survive,
Chinnamasta is not considered
a prominent tantric deity today.
Shrines dedicated to
the goddess are rare,
but Chinnamasta surfaces
in many Hindu and Buddhist
paintings and practices.
During the Hindu
festival of Kali Puja,
which celebrates Kali,
one neighborhood in the
Indian city of Cuttack
celebrates the goddess via
the veneration of Chinnamasta,
while many across India
celebrate Chinnamasta Jayanti,
the goddess's designated day,
by engaging in rituals
to eliminate
negativity and longing.
As a figure who
nourishes herself
while being consumed by others,
who fulfills herself as
she gives herself away
and who embraces destruction
even as she vanquishes death,
Chinnamasta is a goddess
who dispels duality.
And although self-decapitation
is her signature act,
this doesn't mean that she
leaves her body behind.
Instead, Chinnamasta shows
us that we can nourish
our physical bodies
and free our minds,
and that these processes
are eternally intertwined.
If you love the outdoors,
we think you'll really enjoy
the newest digital
series from PBS
called "America
Outdoors: Understory."
Hosted by Baratunde Thurston,
the show explores
our passionate,
yet complex relationship
with the natural world.
Along the way, you
get to meet everyone
from surfing scientists
to fossil hunters.
There's a link in
the description.
We hope you go check it out,
and then maybe go
get some fresh air.
Accessibility provided by the
U.S. Department of Education.